yet another Republican has been caught
committing voter fraud a Republican's
wife has been arrested for casting
23 fraudulent votes for her husband
remember voter fraud of this kind is
very rare
but when we find it it's almost always
Republicans Insider reports that Kim
Fong Taylor was arrested and accused of
multiple counts of voter fraud
prosecutors say that she cast 23
fraudulent votes for her husband in the
2020 election her husband Jeremy Taylor
is an elected Republican there's an 11
page indictment it is wild it claims
that Kim phuong Taylor quote visited
numerous households within the
Vietnamese community in Woodbury County
she collected absentee ballots from
people who weren't there
filled them out cast the ballots herself
quote causing the casting of votes in
the names of residents who had no
knowledge of and had not consented to
the casting of their ballots Taylor is
also accused of signing voter
registration forms on behalf of
residents who were not present that's a
crime in total it is 26 counts of
providing false information three counts
of fraudulent registration and 23 counts
of fraudulent voting each charge carries
a maximum five-year prison sentence
wow the goal was to get her husband
elected I want to remind people again
and again and again and I will continue
saying this until I don't need to say it
anymore voter fraud is very rare it's
also a pretty futile strategy that is
not likely to win an election and the
potential consequences of getting caught
make it very much not worth the risk up
to five years potentially for each of
those counts she's not going to get you
know it's 50 counts total five years
she's not going to get 250 years we I
will bet any amount of money on that but
the risk reward is very much out of
balance voter fraud is a really
ineffective and inefficient way to try
to win an election because the number of
fraudulent votes
is almost always too small to actually
impact the outcome and the risk of
getting caught for voter fraud is high
now Republicans will say everybody's
getting away with voter fraud all these
Democrats are getting away with it the
truth is
there's no reason to believe that that's
the case and we've seen the Brennan
Center for justice study the numbers the
penalties for being caught are severe it
is a really bad political strategy It's
relatively easily detected and it would
be better for these people to spend
their energy on activating voters help
make the case that voters should vote
for a candidate because they think that
that candidate would actually do good
things for them I know it's like a crazy
thing to think about but that would be a
much better way to spend your time and
the last element of this is
when people get caught
it's almost always Republicans even
though Republicans claim it's Democrats
that do this now one could say David
Democrats are doing it but they're
getting away with it Republicans are
getting caught but way more Democrats do
it and get away with it well you've got
to defend that with some data why is it
that Democrats are so much smarter and
able to get away with it there is no
evidence of that whatsoever are you
tired of the same old off-the-shelf
grocery store honey look no further than
manukora our sponsor the honey is made
by bees that pollinate the native Manuka
trees in the remote forests of New
Zealand it gives it a unique dark Rich
delicious flavor that you won't find in
any other honey it is 100 raw if you
look at it side by side with regular
boring honey you can see the difference
I've got my Honeys next to each other on
the counter and it looks very different
manukura is also responsible and
sustainable all all manukura honey is
harvested using traditional methods so
you can enjoy your creamy caramel honey
knowing that the production was easy on
the bees and on the planet I've been
adding manukura honey to my tea and my
toast it's a great natural sweetener in
any recipe it really stands out from
everyday honey so don't settle for the
ordinary honey when you can enjoy the
unique delicious flavor of manukura go
to manukora.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman for a free pack of honey sticks
very nostalgic to when I was a kid with
your order a 15 value tastes the
difference for yourself the link is down
below